[Music]  Ellen DeGeneres turned the big 6o on  Friday January 26 and celebrated the  milestone birthday with the help of some  celebrity pals Justin Timberlake video  conferenced in from his Super Bowl  rehearsals and serenaded the talk-show  host with a soulful rendition of happy  birthday  [Applause]  [Music]  join in with us if that weren't enough  he sent over a bouquet of pink peonies -  that's so sweet  all of you chipped in on this later in  the show frequent guests Kristen Bell  stopped by and presented the bday girl  with a t-shirt that read it took 60  years to look this good but I don't  think it's pointing to your face I think  it's pointing to your heart but the best  gift of all might have come from Belle's  hubby Dax Shepard who sang the host  something more original few a single  entry  [Music]  [Applause]  the way  so crazy  you